I think it's one of the biggest scandals
I've ever seen and you don't cover it
you want to talk about well because it
can't be verified I want to talk about
insignificant things I'm telling you of
course it can be verified excuse me they
found the laptop Leslie listening
what can't be verified the laptop why do
you say that because even the family
hasn't that's interesting because that
was on 60 Minutes two years ago and 60
Minutes is a part of CBS well you're not
going to believe this guys but here's
CBS yesterday confirming everything that
Leslie Stahl said wasn't true two years
ago and as Republicans take control of
the house Hunter Biden the president's
son will be a target for investigations
and that means data from a laptop
reported to belong to Biden could be
crucial to the investigatory process CBS
News has obtained its data not through a
third party or political operative but
directly from the source who told us
they provided it to the FBI under
subpoena and we commissioned an
independent forensic review to determine
its authenticity senior investigative
correspondent Catherine Harris joins us
now with what we've found Catherine I'm
very interested good morning Good
morning Tony these house Republican
investigations are coming and that could
be a challenge for the White House as we
head into 2023 and 2024. the laptop data
we had analyzed showed no evidence it
was faked or tampered with
digital forensic investigator Mark
lanterman was previously a member of a
secret service electronic crimes task
force there was one thing that got my
attention and that was a voicemail
loving more than the whole world pal
foreign
that voicemail apparently from Joe Biden
during his son Hunter's drug addiction
is one of many findings lanterman used
to authenticate what is believed to be
Hunter Biden's laptop data you're
confident based on your analysis this is
Hunter Biden's data and that it's real
yes okay so congratulations to CBS which
two and a half years later is starting
to catch on to exactly guys exactly what
the New York Post reported on two and a
half years ago what the mainstream media
does what corporate press does is they
put truth on A Time release pill right
so you swallow it but you don't get
truth till two and a half years later
once they've figured out how to
re-engineer society and make you think
all sorts of crazy things and wish win
the elections the way they want them to
be won then suddenly the truth starts
leaking out all anyone at CBS had to do
that anchor there I'm very interested in
this well okay anchor on CBS did you
think of maybe picking up the phone and
calling somebody at New York Post two
and a half years ago and saying hey New
York Post guy you guys put out this
really controversial thing I'd be
interested in knowing what your sources
were and maybe then I could report on it